we had a couple of these fights in
orange that were
around this time one of which i started
to tell you about the painting you know
and i know i've interrupted you know
twice on that but i realized the jury
doesn't can you tell them what you mean
by orange at orange
sorry orange was my apartment that i
kept in los angeles at the time
and it was an apartment what type of an
apartment
i rented the top of a duplex so it was a
house and with the landlord living on
the bottom floor i
rented the top floor okay thank you now
please continue with the painting i'm
sorry
i nothing i could it seemed like nothing
i could say to johnny would convince him
he wanted me to remove the painting
and he wanted me to admit
to this affair that i wasn't having
and
i didn't want to admit to it because
it's not true
so i held out
and
he just started i mean he just drank
more and did more cocaine and i woke up
the next morning i think it was on the
22nd or the 23rd i woke up in the
morning and he was the breakfast table
was like
cocaine
and booze
and
i realized that
there
that
i wasn't going to be able to talk
my
like i wasn't going to be able to talk
our our our situation down i was going
to be able to talk him out of it and he
was just so convinced that i was
fighting with him or or or at the reason
that he wouldn't leave the house and he
had something to go film that was
important and there were important
people waiting for him and i remember
people were reaching out
assistants his
manager sister
you know everyone was wondering where he
was and i
kind of i kept feeling embarrassed and
unable to move this person
out of my house i couldn't calm him down
i couldn't change
he was just so intent on me admitting
the details of this affair that i i
wasn't having
and me pointing out that the cocaine
wasn't making his situation any better
made me the bad cop
then i'm the nag
um so eventually i called my sister
uh he had a kind of a buddy relationship
with her
at the time and at the time she
occasionally did cocaine
i didn't but she did so i was like hey
come take over
you know maybe you can buddy buddy him
and talk him into leaving the house
just getting out of the house
and she did um
i remember
his assistance trying to get him out
like we eventually in the evening i
think early evening he finally
agrees to leave but i can't tell our
relationship status i can't tell if he
still is convinced of these things or if
he's just going to sleep it off and
it's going to go back to
normal sobriety sorry
kind of phase
and
uh he
was still upset but
like seemingly calming down so i
i agreed to go with him he wanted me to
go to the to the shoot
i had plans so i kind of reluctantly
agreed but didn't want to set anything
off i didn't want to engage anymore i
didn't want to do anything it could be
perceived as
antagon antagonizing him or engaging
more so i went with him
we grabbed the dogs we get in the car
we're on the way there we're headed up
sweets the street
it's a major street that uh leads up to
johnny's houses
um he effectively owns the end of the
street it's like a cul-de-sac um so
we're
nowhere near his home but we are driving
up this street and uh he has the window
down he's smoking
it wasn't all the way down
but you know he's constantly smoking and
at some point he
starts howling
out of the window and then grabs with
two small dogs well one was johnny's dog
and one was my dog but
he grabs
if i if i remember correctly boo the
the his his dog
um slightly
chunkier
teacup yorkie and he grabs this
teacup yorkie and holds
boo out of the window of the moving car
and
he's howling
like
like an animal okay and
remember you said that you took this
that morning is that correct
could you tell the jury what the boxes
that has the property with the skull
bones property of jd
um that's johnny's um
drug box i've seen it used for pills but
at the time it was um bags of coke like
bags of coke okay and what are these
white lines on the table to the left of
that box
that is cooking what is the bag the
brown bag on the left side what is that
that's a
dopp kit it's um
like
you know his prescriptions and um
cigarette tobacco weed things
like that